i
[Música]
marion col estaría a punto de caer bajo
el control de los rusos tenemos jugó el
ministerio de defensa sostiene que ya
controla todas las partes urbanas y le
dio un ultimátum a las fuerzas
ucranianas para que se rindan mientras
que la presidencia de ucrania advierte
que si matan a los militares que
resisten las negociaciones se acaban
emanuel máxima del epen redoblan sus
esfuerzos en la campaña presidencial
francesa el actual mandatario visitó
marsella para intentar conquistar a los
votantes de izquierda y la
ultraconservadora viajó a una región
donde ya ganó además hubo protestas en
contra de la extrema derecha
un buque con más de 750 toneladas de
combustible náufrago en el golfo de
gabes en túnez el ministerio de medio
ambiente de ese país sostiene que por
ahora no hay fuga de diésel y que espera
que el tiempo mejore para enviar buzos a
verificar el estado de la carga
bienvenidos de nuevo a las noticias de
france 24 yo soy maría clara calle y
comenzamos con la actualidad de la
guerra en ucrania rusia dice que ya
controla todas las áreas urbanas de la
ciudad costera de mariupol el ministerio
de defensa ruso agregó que cerca de 2500
tropas ucranianas son las que aún
resisten dentro de una fábrica de acero
si mariupol cae por completo sería una
victoria militar importante para moscú
pues la ciudad conecta con la península
de crimea anexada por rusia en 2014 y
con la región separatista del donbass lo
que les daría el control de un valioso
corredor en el sur de ucrania esto fue
lo que dijo rusia sobre la urbe ya toda
la zona urbana de mariupol ha sido
completamente liberada de los militantes
de la formación nazi a son mercenarios
extranjeros y tropas ucranianas los
restos del grupo ucraniano están
actualmente completamente bloqueados en
el territorio de la planta metalúrgica
de asoex tal previamente el presidente
ucraniano volodymyr selenski advirtió
que kiev terminaría las negociaciones
con el kremlin si las tropas enviadas
por moscú eliminan a los militares que
quedan en mayo paul el ministerio de
defensa ruso respondió que si las
fuerzas de ucrania deponen las armas les
respetaran sus vidas selenski agregó que
su gobierno está en contacto con quienes
aún resisten en la ciudad costera
y estamos en contacto con los soldados
que están en una fábrica cerrada estamos
en contacto con ellos hay una crisis
humanitaria falta comida agua medicinas
sin embargo los muchachos están
defendiendo heróicamente les estamos
agradecidos por esos pero el
agradecimiento no es suficiente por lo
que se están elaborando otros planes y
procesos de negociación honestamente no
hay confianza en los negociadores rusos
espacio político
las tropas de rusia atacaron las dos
ciudades más importantes de ucrania
después de más de dos semanas de haberse
retirado de kiev los rusos bombardearon
una fábrica de armas cerca de la capital
donde presuntamente se construyeron los
misiles que habrían hundido al buque
insignia ruso moscas
por segundo día consecutivo kharkiv la
segunda ciudad más grande de ucrania
sufre los brutales bombardeos de las
fuerzas rusas así quedó este local
comercial
clic le estábamos haciendo pan cuando la
explosión hizo temblar las paredes todos
salimos corriendo la explosión fue tan
grande que al principio no entendíamos
lo que estaba pasando
según las autoridades ucranianas al
menos una persona falleció y otras 18
resultaron heridas por la metralla del
kremlin que continúa intensificando sus
ataques en el este del país
llegaron tres vehículos con voluntarios
estaban gravemente heridos y todos
sangrando los servicios de emergencias
se los llevaron en cuanto a los que
murieron cerca de aquí mataron a un
joven que estaba atendido allí se podía
ver la sangre en el asfalto corría hacia
él pero ya estaba muerto más fuerte
moscú aseguró este sábado que atacó una
fábrica de misiles cerca de kiev con al
menos un muerto en represalia por el
hundimiento de su buque insignia en el
mar negro las calles de la capital
muchos ucranianos intentan retomar sus
vidas
pese al sonido de las sirenas que avisa
a los civiles de huir a los refugios
[Música]
aquí pero en general por supuesto todo
es muy triste tensos los bombardeos
continúan hoy ha habido bombardeos por
lo que hay alertas de ataques aéreos la
situación es difícil y no te sientes
completamente seguro tenemos las maletas
listas para salir en cualquier momento
si la situación vuelve a escalar todos
los escombros
moscú ha afirmado que su principal
objetivo es la toma total de la región
del donbass con el recrudecimiento de la
ofensiva rusa en el este de ucrania
muchos civiles esperan desesperados
poder salir a otras áreas a través de
los nuevos corredores humanitarios
acordados en la región del lugar donde
se están viviendo fuertes bombardeos
pasamos a francia donde se intensifica
la campaña por la presidencia a una
semana de la segunda vuelta electoral el
mandatario de manuel bajón visito
marsella para intentar conquistar los
votos que sacó el izquierdista luminoso
en la primera ronda mientras que la
ultraconservadora ma jin lepén estuvo en
san jaime efe donde ella ya había ganado
la gira ocurrió mientras que en parís y
otras ciudades francesas miles de
personas salieron a protestar en contra
del ascenso de la extrema derecha
fervor de los manifestantes contra la
extrema derecha son miles los que se han
reunido este sábado en parís y en otras
ciudades francesas
todos ellos preocupados porque ma jin
lepén esté a las puertas del poder
no vale pn en el elíseo se escuchan las
arengas en las pancartas los mismos
mensajes llamando a los jóvenes a
bloquear la agrupación nacional sin
embargo sin llamar sistemáticamente al
voto por macro no tienes que elegir el
enemigo contra el que quieres luchar
durante el próximo mandato y está claro
que hay que elegir yo elijo mantener la
democracia para poder seguir luchando
los próximos cinco años
no soporto que la extrema derecha llegue
al poder
espero vivir eso en mi vida la situación
desde este punto de vista me parece
dramática gracias
una semana antes de la segunda vuelta de
las elecciones presidenciales este
escenario es tomado muy en serio por los
manifestantes a la cabeza de las
procesiones sindicatos y organizaciones
como ése o ese racismo o la liga de los
derechos humanos han venido a defender
las libertades la justicia y la igualdad
ahora en peligro según los organizadores
lleva el fascismo hay una mentira social
muy fuerte y estamos aquí para
denunciarlo cuando vemos el destino que
reserva a los extranjeros los ataques a
las mujeres los lg betis es inmenso los
riesgos están en todas partes
en parís se produjeron algunos
enfrentamientos entre los manifestantes
y la policía
las autoridades consideran que la
concentración es arriesgada porque la
procesión reuniría a varios
manifestantes incluidos los chalecos
amarillos y manifestantes radicales
el gobierno de perú defiende la
castración química para quienes violen a
menores de edad el presidente pedro
castillo le pidió al congreso que tome
medidas más drásticas para proteger a
los niños y niñas luego de que una menor
de 3 años fuera secuestrada y violada en
la ciudad norteña de chiclayo conectamos
a esta hora con lima dónde está cinthia
silva ella es abogada especializada en
justicia de género y directora de la
organización demus perú señora silva
bienvenida a france 24 para que la
castración química entre en el código
penal es necesario que primero el
congreso la apruebe el gobierno ha
propuesto algún proyecto de ley en este
sentido
actualmente buenas noches no encontramos
proyectos de ley que estén en agenda
para debatirse una medida como esa
recientemente más bien en el año 2018
nuestro código penal ha sido modificado
y se han incorporado
penas mucho más drásticas de las que ya
existía
actualmente la sanción para casos como
el que ha ocurrido es una tragedia en
nuestro país
pues merece la pena de cadena perpetua
eso según nuestro código penal y la
última modificatoria de 2018 y según
esta última modificación de la que usted
nos habla qué tan factible es política y
jurídicamente que una propuesta como la
castración química se apruebe en perú y
desde su punto de vista es una media
efectiva para evitar casos de violación
o no
y lo que han mostrado estás
modificatorias que han tenido que ver
con el recrudecimiento de las penas es
que la este tipo de sanciones tanto
cadenas perpetuas como la más aún una
castración química son respuestas
populistas que son
ineficaces para responder a una
problemática que requiere más bien
políticas públicas profundas de
transformación de los sentidos comunes
de transformación de una base social que
lamentablemente todavía se sostiene en
relaciones discriminatorias
en
sentidos discriminatorios y machistas
respecto de el trato a las mujeres y
también esto incluye a las niñas
entonces lo que realmente necesitamos en
nuestro país son políticas públicas con
presupuesto en educación sexual integral
en prevención de la violencia y en
erradicación de los estereotipos
de género que sostienen este tipo de
conductas y las masculinidades
tradicionales machistas señor cinthia
silva gracias por estar con nosotros en
france 24 y pasamos a otras noticias
porque un barco petrolero cargado con
750 toneladas de combustible náufrago
frente al golfo de gabes en túnez
mientras se desplazaba desde egipto
hacia malta el ministerio de
medioambiente tunecino afirma que es
probable que se evite un gran
derramamiento y aunque afirmó que el
contenido del buque está controlado las
ong locales siguen preocupadas por la
zona de pesca marítima
inspección y gestión de los daños las
autoridades tunecinas se desplazaron el
sábado a la costa sureste mientras se
intensifican las labores de control
después de que un buque mercante que
transportaba 750 toneladas de diesel se
hundiera a primera hora de la mañana
creemos que el casco sigue estanco y no
hay ninguna fuga por el momento estamos
esperando que el tiempo mejore
especialmente el viento y las olas para
permitir a los buzos comprobar el estado
del casco y el estado de la carga y por
supuesto para tomar las siguientes
medidas como bombear o acercar el barco
para asegurar la carga los aceites y
todo lo demás tus equipos y el buque que
lo tenía una ruta trazada desde el
puerto egipcio de día meta hasta malta
pero el mal tiempo hizo que la
tripulación emitirá un llamado de
socorro para solicitar la entrada en
aguas tunecinas a última hora del
viernes la sala de máquinas se vio
envuelta en serios problemas y el cello
acabó hundiéndose en el golfo de gabes
se ubicaron barreras de protección para
contener la propagación de petróleo y
acordonar el barco los siete miembros de
la tripulación están a salvo el
ministerio de medio ambiente anunció un
plan de acción para evitar una
catástrofe marina y dijo que el gobierno
no dudará en pedir ayuda extranjera si
es necesario el fondo mundial para la
naturaleza con sede en el país dijo que
teme por la zona de pesca que sostiene a
cientos de trabajadores
la justicia turca abrió esta semana un
proceso judicial para cerrar la mayor
organización feminista del país en un
intento para callar uno de los
colectivos más críticos del presidente
turco recep tayip erdogán nuestro
corresponsal en estambul adrià rocha nos
trae los detalles
esta última semana la justicia turca ha
anunciado su intención de cerrar la
mayor asociación feminista del país se
trata de la plataforma pararemos los
feminicidios y se les acusa entre otras
cosas de ser inmorales e ir en contra de
los valores de la familia
no luchan en contra de los feminicidios
sino que luchan en contra de nuestros
esfuerzos vemos que es una posición muy
contradictoria aunque tendrían que
luchar en contra de los perpetradores y
los asesinos vemos que luchar en contra
nuestra
en esta tierra se gestionan las mujeres
porque quieren tomar sus propias
decisiones y los tribunales les dan a
los asesinos unos descuentos especiales
por ejemplo porque visten bien porque se
arrepienten porque habían sido
provocados por desgracias vivimos en un
sistema extremadamente patriarcal y así
lo reflejan nuestros jóvenes desde hace
varios años el gobierno de turquía no
cuenta el número de feminicidios que
ocurre en un año del país y la única
situación que lo hace es la plataforma
para demostraste ministerios según ellas
a más de una mujer es gran turquía a
manos de su novio marido padre hermano o
desconocido james de quien ya nadie
tiene
[Música]
en nuestro país los asesinatos a mujeres
están subiendo sin fin y por eso estamos
aquí para protestar por todo lo que
sufrimos cada día por el simple hecho de
ser mujeres proyecto
[Música]
y
todos los que estamos aquí nos
levantamos por la mañana con noticias de
una mujer que ha sido asesinada cerca no
es de casos aislados de lejos no ocurren
por todos lados sufrimos miedo a salir a
la calle de noche y por eso luchamos
para poder vivir
turquía hace algo más de un año abandonó
la convención de estambul un acuerdo
internacional para la protección de las
mujeres desde ese momento el número de
feminicidios de asesinatos de mujeres no
ha hecho más que incrementar en el país
anatolio
corea del norte lanzó dos nuevos misiles
hacia el mar esta vez probaron una arma
guiada táctica con la que los
norcoreanos quieren reforzar sus
capacidades nucleares la agencia estatal
de noticias del país la cacn afirmó que
el líder norcoreano kim jong-un observó
las pruebas y que las nuevas armas
mejorarían la artillería de largo
alcance en lo que va a 2022 corea del
norte ha intensificado sus ensayos
nucleares disparando al menos una decena
de misiles
hasta aquí las noticias en france 24 los
invitamos a que consulten nuestro portal
web france24 puntocom nos vemos en
minutos para más información
[Música]